okay everybody our next talk is by a
young optimization guru yes Lee who is
currently an MSR and the movie Buda
thank you
so today I will talk about some recent
progress for the sampling column this is
a last-minute change of the talk because
in this today we saw a lots of MC MC
aode so maybe this cockpit this freemore
so let me first start with something
unrelated talking about my tomb my dream
is if you keep Amir colors out of my
teasing comb I can look at the formula
and Harry what is the optimal way to
stop this poem but this tomb is too far
away for example just look at a very
simple poem we given a graph with MSA
and ever test we consider the min SDK
for this is the this can be written as a
correspond then we can ask how can we
solve this by just staying at this
formula and turns out there is many way
to do this for example you can lay the
people so you can figure power all the
Kuwaitis of this this is the current
waveform we know how to compute gradient
then we can for example you can smooth
this form a little bit like this then
this is a smooth poem we can apply less
of gradient descent on this of all
example if you talk notice is lost only
colors you can turn it at some time here
to make it strongly covered but remember
we our file acquiesce to software with
your problem so when you add something
like this you need to bring about how
much ever you occur by smoothing that
out and then to to NSS carefully and
turns out if you try to use exactly the
design of this you get wanting Tom
Bosley like M 21.5 also for example if
you try to written the origin format the
LP and sophis by using the parsing
software again you get m to 1.5 also you
can think of this one is the packing LP
how about using the latest packing LP
album
again you will get em 21.5 and I don't
know how many before I can tell on this
but but you in the students way the TCS
way of thinking about the problem is
eventually what we want to understand is
lot particular model instead we want to
suffer very special ipod but how can we
stop that as fast as possible
maybe the quitting or quiz blocker only
way to do this and so in the last past
few years I've been trying to understand
keeping a palm what kind of all codes I
think we should bring about and what
kind of album which to decipher their
Oracle setting for example this o intern
so in the last few years much you get a
whistle I am to March each other with is
tough I don't remember the year multi
Katowice all I am to ten or seven for
this so is at least better than all
those classical album for this setting
and I get a one income lock comparative
both but something like this so more
generally you can think about the mean
cross through poem and also by looking
on the formula you notice this is a LP
and this is the capacity costing each
row of this matrix have to don't you but
just by using this set in fact we can
stop being obscure anthem president the
people's to specify cell phone for this
platform and here is an example as a
module minimizing this is pretty popular
in machine language Denis so here is the
poem we want to minimize the function
over all the subset and is pursuing
satisfied admission return lovely if you
have to success TSP contingent s the
benefit of adding actual admin on a
larger subset is more than the benefit
of adding an element on the smaller one
and this poem is way from the mentoring
community ultimately thing you capture a
lot of poem people care and turns out
the the to thing we look at is this
fencing this poem is the colors of the
messaging you can extend to hypercube
and also there's a gradient of F can be
compute in a square table by using
quitting before just using cities to
first we gather and repel from fastest
and peoples specialized alpha man to the
part and with this is just try to
motivate what I'm trying to do lower
going back to the gym in order to
understand how we keep in the formula
come up with album then we need to
decide some operation to handle this and
turn so go sides of water and strike we
have defy a certain type of operation
which is expressly useful for
combinatorial automating we are keeping
a commerce at ke depart for different
operations membership Oracle Tiffin X we
want to check whether X is in the set or
a lot separation Oracle keeping the eggs
we want to check where they pitch to a
CSV in K or you want to find a
hyperplane separate X and K rip off with
with also keeping the direction you want
to find them the rip of the conversation
a lot that I racing just in the seed
Allison and the last Oracle optimize
instead of just computing the R if you
want to find the pawn optimized for data
resting so recently a lot really
recently a few decades ago again there's
other cool people study expressly by
centers so this is a sample code given
the lock concave disappearing tree we
want to sample according the streets of
subject to K and the latter also I will
talk about using integrating integrate G
along K so turns out
of those all Korea's polynomial
equivalent to each other and this is one
of the major source we how we prove a
certain form is polynomial time a lot
and certainly for me then let you
question is can we get a tight
equivalence between all those palm maybe
you think those are curious a little bit
opportunity so I will show diagram for
this I listen to file loosing first for
any conferencing F we defy to do of a
fiesta formula or two with defy one of
Kate the we to fight for every converse
that we can relate with a commerce
person which is you sitting outside the
set and fuel inside and turn off those
Oracle can be written as those formula
so he membership is just dividing this
person separating is just computing sub
greater of this pressing and turns up
with use computing the function value of
the till and ultimately Singh is
computing the separation of the two and
also the integration and there is tilt
as I am just repeating here look is the
bottom if you integrate the bottom
column you will get the first column in
some sense so members of all creatures
devising the printing and you can pull
toy soldiers secreting or you can print
the grading of deference in terms that
will give you a separation hyperplane
and this is just a venture do of the
person you computer where low terms of
this give you the whip through the loop
one after elfin thing response here the
isle questing' is in feet here outside
and fuel inside and ultimately Singh is
the up gradient and the integration work
is always related you can written here I
okay I think maybe the relation is not
accurate for example this one you can
put the alien saya something like this
Oh on my bi way and this way T
integrating is just G e like a tip LK is
the integration and the sampling is you
simply according to g ye l cake just a
sampling
so your few integrators you get that and
yeah it's not that we later that LG is
the input so c is the input and X is the
input G's anyone respond lock and key
participation so e to the minus G is it
all compute or G is lock concave so all
you can written eating like a tip some
fancy good and currently I'm still
trying to working with Santos and LM we
believe really close to getting a pipes
polymer you coupons for the lab for guy
the main problem is to put the lower bar
we've already have the upper part little
paw it's really difficult for us and in
some sense you can think how I sort of
my facing it's just the relation between
suppressing and optimization to also
traditional people printers we just
think album is pretty inefficient for
example the that you could follow me
prefer to be reaching the two categories
by Euler method and usually people
fingers of F is not working at all and
recently we have some efficient version
of the ellipsoid method in fact we have
some natural type guarantee so I think
you yeah there is some opportunities for
those type of things even for practical
setting
and you know they talk I will focus on
how we get from membership to sampling
yeah so so let me choose we kept the
sampling form we're given a color set
and we want to sample upon state
policies we want to sample according to
uniform distribution in the previous
slides we talked about the more general
question we're also keeping a lot from
50 to pitching and then we want to
sample a part according to that why it
is useful turns out there is a very
basic operating for many stuff for
example first of all you can use this
for automating because if you know how
to sample a lot completely super soon
you just little sample e to elective F
but you rescale F by a lot then after
you sample with high poverty you get a
punch close to minimum also it is used
for you to creasing chanting learning
wanting also I think the funny thing is
this is the current best way to minimize
the college funding if we only have a
lot see function value Oracle originally
are yeah also the best way to compare
bottom set volume of converters today I
will only focus off on these punches
sample from uniform distribution but
most of the technique can be transferred
to that and we just do that for the low
tasting simplicity and original I
promise to give this talk so I at least
skipped over so and terms of the ism
turns out one not super application of
sampling is how to solve the color
palette but this is a lot of your
application there is much more thing to
do to get this result this is John work
with SAP and modern so the palm setting
is a little bit different you can think
this poem is very very worst case of
colors out of my session we want to rope
us in a perch in lights
so the palm is like this you can finish
a game
it's step that adversity we will choose
give you a different colors for thing
and you you can choose upon you in the
user part in sometimes you only want to
minimize the L on the EULA per your
concert and it will depends on some
parts of servicing and then you will
receive the lost LS there and that is
the only information you know about the
person and then you del x1 divert the
river juice and everything and then you
choose enter pot and you only receive
the cocktail and nothing else you know
about Al you know that this problem to
make sense we measure the performance by
request the performance like this this
is some of the cost you get from the
lost person you can pay against to a
fixture jury you minimize over X in the
unifor and some of those l notice
because we measure the performance by
this system is kind of saying if this
term is more them in taste and little
fixed good perfect strategy that means
doing the album although we almost low
doping about the L which is keep
changing with can still roughly gets way
is the effective strategy and this form
is typical because imagine you if the
adversary in the half
in the first epsilon posting of the
iteration is just give you some chunky
information telling you the obvious
there then you cannot focus you in there
because you know that verse you can move
and that's why the poem is difficult in
peace
palm setting people would like to bring
about you all together regret life
square t Lotus the request a more
fatigued so if you talk about your fh
request and this is one over booty there
is autumn or even give say the adversary
always choose the same friends impulse
with some additives loss and in
particular they care about getting a one
I'm like oh this hour so it fits it this
is dimension see they want to care when
it am like end to the thousand school mm
and some t22 first one motivation for
this is like for example you're in the
casino and effy locksmith is the linear
fencing you notice one machine is better
than other than them assuming you will
spend off your time on the casino than
you this guarantee is certainly better
than that
so so obviously I promise to talk about
this with you
so is with this we series is based on
many people's we so people have been
studied for this point for that case as
by combining some of them those we saw
as getting some new insights we get the
first problem ultimatum on this the
previous best album have exponential to
n yes so this is your origin formers and
doing the album for example one tightly
we need to use these sampling that's why
you still welcome to this talk yeah good
so now we go back to the sampling calm
so the sampling form turn so we need to
be more specific there's two ways to
bring about the sampling form first is
to always go setting in the oku setting
for example you only have two members
also you can only teleport is in K a lot
also you will promise you're keeping a
pond inside the set otherwise you cannot
find it at all yeah more precisely we
are at the promised you find a pontiff
inside the set just to make sure the
problem excels the ANS setting is the
explicit setting
namely the converse is expecially
confirmed by a polytope our special
hijama
something you like and in this talk we
will focus on portal so first of in the
talk in the first part of the tower will
first talk about the auto setting then i
will talk about the XP
setting oh I should remove that sentence
anyway so the sampling problem here is
the setting just to remind you this form
is 34 long while impetus is only
realized to be polynomial time you 90s
the the prefix path is n cook and the
conjecture lower bound is n square the
lower one is again consider we don't
know that yet tad lo by usually come
from be amazing if the quality is
ellipsoid and remember the members of we
call each iteration only give you one
bit of information that's why we believe
used to being scripted but this is
conjecture and turns out this form
letters have content available we also
have a Content autumn or alpha there is
for walk the album use as symbols as you
could try if you don't know anything
about this form so the alpha me sister
you start with X it situation you look
at the power same with s Delta value and
you sample points inside if the part is
still inside the sets you accept this
sample and continue the sampling step
otherwise you forget about the sample
and do it again so this is for walk
notice this L from this verify for any
set it can be long Congress however if
the test is Lancome as the album can get
checked in certain site imagine if the
status here and you do the poor work if
the bottom line here is very small
tangent will keep going here and to to
measure the performance of this set
basically you just need to measure your
face some bottom net of the set and
turns out that can be measured by
isoparametric castle
given any Commerce Act not any set we
can divide the ISO parametric cost
analysis you search over all the subsets
of case
and then you compute the ratio of the
world the area of the intercept the
battery of the sets divided by the
volume of the smaller size for example
with for this set the fire will be large
because no matter how you cut paste
low-bottom net to the fire will be large
or for example this one the fire will be
small so what was the daughter in the
thousand intercept sighs oh this oh this
is the country of the search this is the
test go to that one doubters that one
Yousef say it's a quick step size doing
the whole album yeah I will go to there
yeah yeah turn so for any search
lobsters comer set turns out the poor
walk will converge in n over Delta
square v square it's racing Delta is the
step size one for you notice is if the
set is harder to cut or if the step size
is larger then it makes faster however
you cannot set the Delta to large
otherwise the failing poverty is one
then we even can dispel step here and
turn so I will first discuss about Phi
and then the Delta turn so for the
isoparametric constant even for the
commissary can be a purchased more
because this this cotton is lot of wagon
variant imagine your process you can
scratch the surface vendor is easy to
cut
for example this converted the fire is
just 1 divided by L UK it at the center
so you little we normalize the tester
state in multiplier for so the way you
do this is you can realize the tester
set the query matrix of the status
identity and turn so we call conversate
is also chopping your face min 2 and
covariance attentive and and so times
there is one extra benefit for this
without molestation turns out your
success is isotropic then you can set
the Delta it's like wonderful would end
and you can make sure the success
probability is constant now we're
putting into the film we told you before
then the four walk will mix in n square
Phi square term and square over Phi
square term what is it given a random
point Oh
because usually for my coaching if you
just start at any pond then you need to
pay lot of the ratio of the distance
teaching to distributing but because
this is high dimension the difference a
lot of the difference will be n so if
you're looking for a random pond in the
beginning you will pay another investor
this other chick you'll make the Lucy
Square angles defense yeah the two to
everything between the resulting
distribution and the uniform
distribution yeah and because this is
loitering in some sense you can take
water and but if the coitus is like the
tropics as a trick to two will
immobilize it basically what you can do
use my chicken egg you can for example n
different pond in the color set and then
you computer and Percoco every matrix
and charge from the space and also the
chicken can be implement you know we go
to the so today's culture is seeing the
chaos congestion see and the isotropic
body have Phi is constant that means if
this is true them the powers will make
see an N squared tuition and this is
touchable for the box even for the
hypercube
imagine you really take the steps are
wonderful with them then for any tie
wrestle with half of it you only move
one over N and because this is a random
walk if your step size is 1 over n then
you were only maxi an N squared step I
remembered a simple metric called jet a
lower bound to working with centers we
still trying to prevent great touch
needs to lower bound for any album but
today I will talk about caressed
contester a little bit just in festivals
I facilities transit areas well study in
PMF for example has many related
conjecture in math one contentious issue
and costly I think on teacher deeply
convert at the cottage I ask if the
cottages EULA volumes that a hyperplane
just as the war the slicing the volume
use constant like that the Android
conception is the Finchel contest the
contest is using keeping the concept the
fears are the topic yet smooth of the
volume is lying in this pin shell Lotus
the whit ACH grow and and the shell have
whipped constant to most of the wall
abuse lying and will be printer tech
culture is kind of really interesting to
me is because for example if you try to
solve in Connecticut mean because mess
with people's album say the LP album
where you stick will and come from and
thanks squirrel and guess what we come
from the fret for any converses you can
oppose me by ellipsoid in this way so
you have a lot so you have commerce
search turns out you can always funny
lift it since I and if you scale that
you list by school and you can take the
holy lips this is how the school and
come from and this demon is way stronger
than this this is loitering commented
about this this only works for
symmetrical versus this day basis any
comment area slot just a possible by
school effort
is that possible by 1 + wonderful Ampata
but this is a publicist famous so we
don't know how to use so this is and the
contest which I think poverty is very
useful for many people this contest is
keeping a lock on key distribution and
one Lipschitz printing I should remove
this sentence turns out a few
concentrated one the mean of F with the
air I is like T with the air is like
constant with exponential probability so
in substance you can think this is some
sort of generalization of channel pan or
leprechaun sentencing which we use a lot
in complete silence yeah anyway -
supplies in some sense all suits
conjecture is easy to put for for the
case the Colossus lives and in substance
all those context changes
I think it's all the converses is look
like he lives and if they look like a
lives then can we say colors ultimate
eating is as easy as being suffering
limit system there is a string I really
want to careful anyway this is we saw
about carrot suit in the first wave
identify the context you take at the
lower part and to one of us QF and after
people found this country is typically
in love so the way you handle this is
the divide simple conjecture instead of
cutting the set by any set your only cap
i ellipse the antenna so that quantity
can be reported made by a simple formula
square and over the Ravens of the lhamo
long square total this is serious
difficult for example you see the first
pan is wonderful school and comes law
square law and is slightly better and
after decades of of airport now we get
into the kitchen from foot and one major
Peck for years by order he show you in
fact
can only search for those that with a
lot of generality
he put the [ __ ] apart me by the Sigma
in the jungle with CentOS we get into
negative 1/4 1/4 yeah in particular this
shows the mixed income of poor workers
and 22.5 yeah one of the purpose of
giving this sampling to yourself
commerce spending is because of a few
days enough audience or MCMC year maybe
I can ask them question the first
question I ask is to read know any
better way to fund them mixing em up for
work this is in some sense the simplest
walk you can imagine yeah so the mixing
time you had with N squared divided by
this pi write something the original
thing that yeah yeah so you are playing
that applies basically and you won't
happen this is a Phi Phi squared yeah
yeah but you want to show that this is
constant so that yeah
yeah yeah so I finished the auto setting
now I go to the expected setting yeah so
literally you look at the research and -
to pop obvious way too large for for
Palmer for billion sites so we want to
ask can you read to it faster you form
your plot in the Oracle chattering so
yeah the problem is again the same
acceptor commerce set is lower part of
this problem is also started before the
previous path is the deacon walk the
lump of filtering is M and notice if M
is the number of constrain your salamba
we're both notice if the lump of costing
is roughly equal to rebels and this is n
square we follow a Sumerian culture and
the one example each iteration involves
offering a linear system so you get a
matrix multiplication car and notice
power walk is n 22.5 each iteration only
involve looking on your LP ones so it's
just mmm and today I will talk about the
geodesic Walker we have slightly better
than a man and with the same cost per
iteration and what was important here is
this is the first subculture tech album
the funny thing is all the people sell
from the bottom that K is the hypercube
and turns out will I turns out our album
for hypercube years light n - one foot
but we cannot show something like that
at all
we only able to show em and so forth
over five so so just to motivate a
little bit
in version namely limiting if you each
interesting it involves sampling from my
lips and to sample for my lips you
little self a linear system and the cost
of solving a linear system you stick in
general you few don't want to depends on
conditional number otherwise you get
something like for example you can
respect fi conjugate gradients then you
get something else
M just a number of equation and just a
lump of a pose oh yeah so you tell how
we sample if you eaten or anything in
some sense the natural way is to follow
the later which is just panning motion
oh it worked really well for just free
space but but the main problem is our
concept has some party so and you hit
the budget easy to deal with that one
natural thing is to refer when you hit
the budget and turns out a is super
difficult to do because imagine you as
the set is a hypercube if you went with
your pond with some high probability you
get close to a freaking swing by some
will some something like one of hood and
and then when you try to do a barnable
thing you will keep hitting the costing
many many times even for small step and
that's what this option is difficult to
do and the end of so we are trying to do
is following the teacher walk out here
we try to remove the budget by folding
up the space in some sense this is the
visual part of we want to do a change of
change of web user set if now pull up on
the budget at low budget at all so after
you sample on this menu features develop
Rajasthan in some sense so however this
idea require explicit title because to
do a random
on this manifold you lead to first
concert this manifold that's why we live
the motive is given in the first place
and so what do I mean by pulling up so
just to give a very simple example say
the coitus is the interval then what I
want to four of years I want to pull up
to real life I stretch the quantity of
the budget is infinity this steps that I
have pandiri anymore so you just need to
do a random walk here but what you'll
notice is if you do a random walk here
you will basically strip to infinity so
this is law uniform disability in fact
it is kind of oh and in some sense you
can think this operation your slave we
try to please tour the spaces that we
convert the heart causing the bungee to
a top country yeah to to describe the
pool up in the general setting a little
explain what is the metaphor
so in some sense you can finger and
dimensional manifold is just layer n
time measuring surface different in a
higher dimensional space like this this
is the manifold and at every pulse stage
the changing space there is just
consists of all the divesting starting
from that pot and then for every pond
stage stage inner product if I do Cooley
and pepper and that's unit for the years
in some sense you can think the best a
manifold just like every pot you you
Esaias more pore here dividing how you
measure the distance and given a given
that unit father is useful for dividing
into the length of a cup it's just you
integrate a lot or the derivative of the
cup but you yourself measured the log by
L to you measured by the unipolar at
that point
and and also you can define a system
between two punches just in Formula One
alone all the path and the length of the
puppy is measured by v length and and in
some sense you can think what we are
trying to do is generalize the pork in
some sense with what we want to to use
yourself
each step we take a simple each step we
choose a different poll depending on the
starting pause so the album use
something similar like this each step
you look at this part
and notice the distance is measured in
the two remaining setting then you step
you just draw a boy in that manifold and
you sample a pot here and you repeat
Lotus oh yeah and what kind of benefit
to you zanter that we use the manifold
crocoseum manifold because they easy to
come up basically you first come up with
a convex function on your point oh then
you divide the unit positing new unipod
away free at the Pompey is just the
inner product comparing in the hassium
at the pond so for any commerce printing
on the poor top we have a corresponding
healthy manifold and in particular in
our analysis we will use the lapel
referencing which is used indian hippo
before the formula is like this the
picture is like this so you are
currently X the lapel referencing is
just lot of 1 over the distance for
every country this first of all you do
is this printing using Depot up on the
bungee when you are getting closer to
one party one of the slack will get
close to 0 so this person will pop and
in some sense what happens is if for
example if you look at Reggie lives at
this pond 20 lives will be really learn
a lot this tiring but very swing on this
service tree
so in some sense our work will be slower
when you are getting close to the pantry
but it's only slower on the direction
you're going towards the pantry for all
other dimensions we will still go really
fast so this is the benefit of using
this compared to the power walk you
always use the for with shrimp strip
yeah so this is the set so this is the
chicken walks people study before and
test the action so this is the deccan
walk so often it's just if each of you
and X you look at the poor confused by
the lapel fencing and you go there I
noticed it out from doesn't work in
futures to this because for example if
you're doing on the interval this walk
is essentially same as panel motion of
the world are you would chip off the
bungee to you oh yeah is a picture and
so the terms of what you need to two
years you do a few things step this is
standing MCMC so the one thing you'll
notice is if you have a map watching if
the macro chicken is symmetric then the
stationary distribution is uniform so
what you need to do to make a buffering
symmetrical yourself instead of T from X
to Y you use the probability X to Y you
use the probability minimum of X to Y
and Y to X please make sure this is
symmetric and this is very easy to
implement what you do is you just sample
according to some approaching
then you check the poverty if the
political impact is way smaller then you
need to flip back on to adjust for that
that fall and so that we describe the
papers without the Deacon Walker album
is just this is step you look at the
poll you develop a referencing and then
you flip back on to compare the volume
and then do accordingly
and they pull it fit album take em and
step this is the better than the people
space for the auto setting if M equals
to n so then so we're trying to
understand carry to better album dentist
the first idea we come up with is this
Lotus what the one special poverty of
self-amused a always sample according to
a lips strictly inside the portal but if
you look at the high dimensional
geometry then you know usually you can
and Laster ulis Y Square and petal with
high poverty is still inside the the
body so why don't we just get the
release by a scroll and pepper and turns
out this just not work
the real problem is turns out a few to
this then the success poverty will be
exponential small you can see this just
in the hypercube amazing after you take
a step you go to there then the volume
which in tattoo is exponentially large
so your success probability is very
small
yeah and in fact hypercube is kind of
the word case for all the people cell
phone we know except Allah referring you
sample every coordinate independently so
what we do is we'll try to go back to
the rebalance the continuous case the
idea is kind of similar to the email
talked yesterday the idea is we
measuring we look at the Deacon work we
try to take the step size tends to sue
and we try to understand what it will
give and if you look at the cecum walk
is kind of special if you stay here
although the sepoys look like this you
have some hope with this sample
here but because if you go to here
there's low poverty going back to the
acceptance step we'll just reject those
sample so you if you chose a possible
why you will go to your Lobby
symmetrical and upon X so there is a
certain trip going towards Center and
you certain see it makes sense because
if you turn to any conference then your
walk will trip to the in pretty and this
company's trying to give you a trip
going back to the center so this is
counter a trip the trip to infinity
issue and if you take the step size 10
to instilled annual test to a stochastic
differential equation also the attack
so stitched up to the stochastic
differential equation is like this is
step you have a teacher mystic step a
trip to or Center and a random step
depending on the ellipse you at that
Park and turns out that yes the truth is
just universe of the Hessian and turns
out you have to confusing is Universal
Cassian and turns out the trip have a
light formula by just applying this
equation so for any sve you can you have
a corresponding diffusion equation by
some formula and remember I'll call you
to converse to your poem distribution so
we set Q on the left hand side then you
will get this by just removing one
derivative then you will see the trip
have an explicit formula of the
diffusion term pretty bad
how many timers okay good so okay I will
at least finish the description of the
walk
so now laterally we have a walking like
this naturally what you could do years
you take a oiler typical teaching them
is you just think the conservative as as
the takfiris terms of detail from
doesn't make sense for example we
imagine earth uses math geography a
certain air manifold the few styie here
turn your futures to the a system you
will just go to some crazy location it
doesn't make sense especially if you
look at the sphere your futures try to
take a step you go outside the manifold
and turn so what we two years this you
magic us that adhere you just to a step
then you go outside the manifold and
turns out William Ramallah melon
potential X referring to two years to
exponential map that mean you want to
find the shortest pasta and eggs with
the divesting on pistol icing then it
will go to hear such oh that's actually
always on the manifold so we get the so
we change the album by this instead of
just to efficient you to exponential map
shooting our geodesic we are
corresponding to F then you gather the
more mature sly yeah but this album
still have a discretization error so we
still to the filtering step with super
car but but notice our alpha me is very
complicated because for every pond you
look at the the Hessian and to the
geodesic then what is the public from X
to Y is decreasing decreasing we can
still improvement back in in in matrix
inversing time but the next question I
have for MC MC committee is usually how
do we avoid those filtering step yeah
anyway I guess I will skip off those one
good part poverty of geodetic s you will
level if the polytope and in fact we can
prove for any geodesic if the servicing
is random than the geodesic have length
and 1/4 so which is pretty good if we
have this probability for YouTube for
method we have much faster elfin for
metal
the any second thing good about the
geodesic is turns out a few yeah okay
okay I skip everything to the last life
okay yeah yeah this is pretty bad
oh yeah I have no the questioning slides
basically Center saying I don't have any
background on TSU Mullen geometry so you
have someone know better than us please
tell us something
and I can't inform how to avoid
filtering step the legs finger I really
want to know yes for now we don't know
where the carrot is true a lot then you
send it general way or just for the
power to tell where their walkies mix a
lot the last equation is in some sense
you camping our walk is a multi map or
the higher order method and the Euler
method is in general use higher order
method useful for STD's the last
question years
do you have other heuristic for sampling
I should know thank you for the next
speaker is telling us for snacking on